[Music]
I'm always looking online you do this a
lot too
I know you do particularly always
forwarding to me funny videos that
you've seen online you see something and
cracks you up well I saw something today
it's a video online of a woman who
claims she owns the world's longest cat
here's the video take a look I saw that
no I swear to God I had this reaction I
just like world's longest captain's
gonna be amazing and then I watched it
I'm like yeah long-long cap it you know
BFD right yeah right good no idea what
that means but anyway I actually looked
into it and it is not even the world's
longest cat what not no internet yeah
and I happen to know the reason we have
a cat here at our show named hoagie that
really is the world's longest cat
let's get hoagie out here you gotta
check out hoagie
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
we don't know why there's that sudden
pump up at the end a third of the way
down hoagie we don't hoagie run over by
a golf yeah I think so hope he doesn't
seem to care
hey now let's meet hoagies owner this is
a double surprise please welcome the
world's longest lesbian this is
incredible
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
let's let's not look at that - huh huh
that's very strange
all right where do you get police best
like that actress is committing so
you're terrific all right let's move on
now I want to talk about something near
and dear goodbye
[Applause]